la situation à montréal inquiète avec
nous la mairesse de montréal valérie
plantes bonsoir madame plan bonsoir
monsieur roy alors 971 cas sur 1 2
million à peu près la moitié des cas à
montréal
vous avez déclaré l'état d'urgence
aujourd'hui d'abord pourquoi aujourd'hui
qu'est ce que ça change
il faut savoir que l'état d'urgence en
fait c'est vraiment les autorités de la
santé publique en accord avec québec est
avec nous avec ça a été déclaré et la
raison pour laquelle on le fait
aujourd'hui c'est que depuis quelques
jours nous on se rencontre le terrain
qu'il y à des personnes surtout les plus
vulnérables à qui on n'arrive pas offrir
tous les tous les ce dont ils ont besoin
et je parle ici de la communauté les
personnes itinérantes et on se rend
compte que à cause des refuges qui doit
fermer
il ya des gens qui sont laissés à eux
mêmes qu'ils n'ont pas nécessairement de
quoi manger qui ne savent pas où aller
dormir alors on sentait que c'était
important de monter doivent faire plus
et avec l'état d'urgence ça nous donne
cette capacité d'action cette agilité
donc vous pouvez comme par exemple
réquisitionner des lieux et comment vous
allez le faire comment vous allez offrir
des abris à ces gens là c'est une très
bonne question
oui en fait les différentes différents
éléments premièrement c'est d'offrir des
des centres de jour parce que les
personnes sans abri dorment dans des
refuges le soir mais durant jour bain en
général y en a qui vont peut-être faire
demander des sous dans la rue donc c'est
comme ça qu'ils arrivent à se nourrir
ils vont aller dans différents endroits
mais là on essaie vraiment de minimiser
les rassemblements alors on va créer des
centres de jour non seulement qu'ils
vont être sécuritaire mais où est ce
qu'on va pouvoir leur donner de quoi
manger pour moi c'était primordial mais
aussi avoir différents lieux pour qu'il
y ait moins de gens dans les refuges de
nuit justement parce que là aussi on
veut respecter les cependant minimisé
les risques de contamination bayer il
faut plus de lieux on va voir une carte
ensemble des quartiers les plus touchés
on parle de côte-des-neiges parc
extension verdun côte st luc
également la salle verdun lasalle
pourquoi là qu'est ce que vous dit la
santé publique de montréal
écoutez pour l'instant on n'a pas autant
d'informations que ça le docteur drew
loin de même à faire le point
on va mettre en place pour expliquer
également différentes mesures qui vont
être appliqués à montréal tout
particulièrement parce qu'il faut qu'il
y ait une recherche en lice et une fois
qu'on est détecté des cas pourquoi d'où
ça vient comment ça se propage alors
j'ai comme toute la population
montréalaise gr 2 d'attendre d'en savoir
davantage mais ce que je veux quand même
dire c'est bien qu'il ya plusieurs cas
dans la partie ouest de l'île de la
ville pardon il ya quand même fort
probablement des foyers ailleurs
prendront dans les rues les plus denses
alors on parle du plateau-mont-royal du
centre-ville du centre ce donc ça ne se
limite pas à ce alors de l'importance de
ne pas baisser la garde alors est-ce
qu'on pourrait en arriver quelles
seraient les prochaines étapes pour vos
sites de d'éclaircir ça parce qu'on soit
énormément de questions les gens nous
demandent ce que on va boucler
montréalais ce convoi bouclé des
quartiers comme on a fait en chine donc
déconfinement obligatoires quelles sont
les prochaines étapes
c'est une très bonne question je sais
que beaucoup de montréalais et des gens
qui par exemple viennent travailler à
montréal qui se posent la question qui
s'inquiètent
moi mon message de dire montréal n'est
pas fermée morial n'est pas en
quarantaine pas aujourd'hui pas demain
non plus si on devait s'en mettre ce
genre de mesures là en place de
confinement de l'île où deux ou deux
quartiers
ça va être fait de façon ordonnée
concertée progrès de façon progressive
parce qu'on sait les impacts alors je
veux vraiment rassuré tout le monde
la ville n'est absolument pas mise en
quarantaine et ce n'est pas dans les
plans évidemment on se prépare à tout et
je pense que c'est normal de le faire et
c'est la façon responsable de naviguer
dans cette crise là mais il ya aucun
plan à court terme de fermer la ville
très bien et qu'elle serait l'élément
déterminant pour en arriver là
est ce que c'est le nombre de cas à
partir d'un certain nombre ont dû bon
ben là vous fermez la ville comment vous
explique sa la santé publique de
montréal qu'elle serait l'élément le
facteur déterminant pour la santé
publique de ce conte
on comprend bien sûr je ne suis pas une
experte mais ça va être si la
propagation
si on se rend compte finalement que ça
serait mieux de fermer certaines
certaines entrées ou sorties pour
limiter la propagation faut savoir que
toutes les mesures qui ont été mises en
place dans les derniers jours
c'est là qu'ont elles portent fruit
alors je veux encore une fois dire à
tout le monde c'est bien ce que l'on
fait qu'il faut continuer à le faire
mais au fur et à mesure qu'on a augmenté
les mesures dans la dernière semaine
moi j'ai bon espoir que ce sera
suffisant ou du moins on va réussir à
contenir la rai qui était décrété par le
premier ministre si tout le monde
respecte ça je pense qu'on va ça va
vraiment donner une chance ça va nous
donner de l'oxygène
donc ce que vous nous dites en clair
c'est que vous espérez encore éviter ce
genre de mesure de bouclage de quartier
ou de bouclage la ville y passe ya
passage réalise pour qu'on évite ça
aurait absolument
vraiment c'est le message que j'ai
aujourd'hui est vraiment le sait c'est
le discours que toutes les autorités ont
la santé publique
le réseau de la santé le gouvernement du
québec la ville de montréal on a tous le
même dit qu'au discours et on travaille
dans ce sens là de là l'importance de
l'état d'urgence maintenant pour nous
permettre justement de limiter la
propagation est simple pour moi là c'est
je suis soulagé aujourd'hui de poids
mettre en place certaines de ces mesures
valérie plantes mairesse de montréal on
voir faire le point comme ça avec vous
bien sûr merci beaucoup de nous avoir
parlé en direct bonne soirée au revoir